good evening good evening welcome I'm
Matthew Spalding I'm associate vice
president and Dean of educational
programs for Hillsdale College here in
Washington DC
welcome to the LMP kirby center for
constitutional citizenship Hillsdale of
course is in Michigan but this is our
campus here in in Washington DC and I
welcome all of you to a great discussion
tonight about a new book out the
unmasking unmasking the administrative
state the crisis of American politics in
the 21st century by John Marini
professor Marini is a professor
political science at the University of
Nevada at Reno and he has written
extensively on this topic for quite some
time in various books and publications
including what I consider a great
classic the politics of budget control
of Congress the presidency in the growth
of the administrative state and he did
some of that work I'm happy to say when
he was here his distinguished resident
fellow of the Kirby Center he's going to
be interviewed by Michael Anton Michael
is a lecturer and research fellow here
at the Kirby Center with Hillsdale
College and he was previously a national
security official in the Trump
administration he writes extensively and
appears regularly on television as a
commentator but he teaches here our
undergraduates here here in DC and also
he will be involved in the Graduate
School of Government we are currently
planning to launch soon here in
Washington DC Universe than that speak
with me or Andrew Hines in the back both
john Marini and michael anton or senior
fellows at the Claremont Institute
John Murray is on the board of the
Claremont Institute and Michael actually
was recently reviewed John's book in the
Claremont Review of Books and they the
Claire - titude is also a co-sponsor
this evenings conversation we thank them
for that so with that I turn it over to
Michael Anton thank you
the review that Matt mentioned I noticed
went online today so everybody's soon as
you get home click it read it I
encourage that I was gonna say I was
here for a while John before you showed
up and I was about to make an
announcement I said look if Marini
doesn't come it's fine I can speak on
his behalf I've been studying you for 25
years I know the book really well I know
what his ideas are I can't even get up
and switch back and forth between chairs
and ask myself questions but he came so
I think it worked out I just wanted to
tell a story
it's not a knee-slapper but might be
mildly amusing about the first time I
met John I've never told him this so it
was 25 years ago I was a published
fellow of the Claremont Institute in
Claremont California it was a small crew
there were only four of us and the
program introduces you to a wide range
of teachers most of whom if not all of
whom received a sort of similar
education the same books the same ideas
the same principles one of them of
course being John Marini I didn't know
him honest I'm sorry I had never heard
of you at that point and this is the
four of us we you know it's in a kind of
a nondescript conference room in a at an
office building in a you know a suburb
of Los Angeles and we heard John Murray
talk about this mystifying thing called
the administrative state for about two
hours and Hegel I'd heard of Hegel calm
- and these names start flying around
and but all four of us stumbled out into
this bright Southern California sunlight
with one sort of reaction amongst the
four of us which we whispered because we
didn't want to be overheard by the
people running the program two of whom
were sitting right over there by the way
and we said to ourselves
Oh on earth was that all about we just
didn't get it
my first or my first experience was kind
of mystification obviously that was deep
and profound but what was it really
about I will say I later encouraged and
recommended and wrote a letter and to a
friend of mine to do a similar program
down the road twelve years later his
experience on first hearing Marini was
entirely different this is because he's
smarter than I am he called me as soon
as it was over and he said wow that was
the most impressive thing I've ever
heard it
you you and you you understood it like
right off the bat so yeah instantly I
got I got it just like that I mean you
didn't actually know I didn't but I I
think I got it now it took a while I I
had to study up and really read and pay
attention because Marini is you know
there's it's dense his ideas are dense
the prose is dense there's a lot going
on so let's get to what is going on I I
guess I want to ask you that you didn't
quote the book is called unmasking the
administrative state which is not a
phrase that you coined no and yet you
have done more than anybody to
popularize it make it known and to
explain what it really means so what in
your education led you to make that what
I would I think is fair to say the
primary focus of your of your scholarly
efforts I think when I started back
almost 40 years ago at least 40 years
ago the administrative state was not a
term that was used at that time it was
really not in the popular language and
not even in the scholarly language in in
in the 70s when I first started I
probably started working on this stuff
about 1975 74 and what I called it then
what I was interested in was the
phenomenon of what Tocqueville called
centralized administration because that
was the term that we thought about as
the culmination of what happens when
when a regime becomes dominated really
by the administrative authority that is
established which at that time I didn't
know the theoretical background of who
how to understand what what the
authority for the administrative state
was because I hadn't done any study of
the political theorists finally I
started studying Hegel and Hegel
describes this better than anyone in
terms of what it's really about
and he doesn't call it the
administrative state he calls it the
rational state it's the rule of
organized or rational knowledge and so
but when I first started it sent
relize administration was i understood
from the point of view thug Ville and
Tocqueville said this is the kind this
is the despot this is what despotism
will look like in democratic times
centralized administration is democratic
despotism and his argument in the second
volume of democracy in America was keep
your institutions decentralized as much
as you can political and administrative
authority has to be decentralized
throughout a particularly a big regime
and once you centralize very difficult
ever to decentralized so he his chapters
on democratic despotism which were
written between 1835 and 1840 are very
revealing about this phenomenon and even
before it it had a name either in terms
of bureaucracy wasn't a widely used word
even in French and took those time Hegel
doesn't use it at all so the
administrative state the bureaucratic
state whatever you want to call it what
distinguishes it in my mind is the
authority that moves from political rule
to administrative rule which is rule
from which is a transition from
political rule on behalf of the people
or political rule in which the people
participate in their own self rule the
rational rule which is ruled by
organized intelligence organized
knowledge and now when Hegel established
the the goal of how it is that rational
Authority is going to be established
within what comes to be known as the
bureaucracy he didn't quite know or have
a method of establishing how that
knowledge is going to be generated
knowledge indeed in the administrative
state or the rational state is produced
as its create as its created to solve
the problems that exist in each
particular epoch and in doing in
establishing
what he's doing with what the state is
the idea of the state is a vehicle or
the administration of progress and the
mechanism for establishing the knowledge
as to how to bring about progress about
is the bureaucracy now I'm using these
terms as we would now use them so the
bureaucracy although bureaucracy was a
term that really means just rule of the
desks in French what what was required
to solve the problems of politics of
society what was required to do that of
course was knowledge but there was no
method by which you can establish
rational knowledge there were no social
sciences yet so Tocqueville I mean Hegel
did not have established what the role
of bureaucracy was to manufacture or
produce organized knowledge or
intelligence on behalf of the solution
to problems that arise at the end of
history when politics essentially is
over and in a certain way religion is
over the big problems are over and they
should be replaced by administration
which will be a technical problem and by
religion by the secular deity as Hegel
calls it to state itself because the
state is not merely a rational
organization it's also going to be an
ethical organization so all of these are
brought together in that thought now
when Michael talks about cult and I'm
not talking about an annual condom
talking about Auguste Comte he was the
man who established the social science
discipline the method the means by which
to generate knowledge so all of the
social sciences really are born at the
end of the 19th century on the with the
demise of both philosophic and religious
authority philosophic and religious
authority is being diminished by the end
of the 19th century and scientific
Authority has replaced
yeah rational scientific knowledge and
so this this this administrative state
doesn't come back into the usage of
modern political science until the end
of the 20th century now at the end of
the nineteenth century the state itself
as a concept that yelling consequence
was absolutely essential to the
development of political science Woodrow
Wilson wrote a book on the state they
all talked about the state and they
minced the state conceptually in Hegel's
terms so I don't want to get too far
into that maybe I said let Mike play
both parties out okay
we sort of in the middle of what you
said said that the authoritative factor
for this is organized intelligence or
knowledge and I'm gonna put those both
in scare quotes right now to what extent
is that intelligence genuine
intelligence that supercedes fill of
philosophic intelligence and to what
extent is the alleged knowledge actually
knowledge I mean I know my answer is in
neither cases did it didn't work out as
promised but I'd like to hear your well
think about it for a minute the the
great hope for social science was that
philosophic and religious authority had
had thousands of years to solve the
human problems of poverty disease crime
every every expectation at the end of
the 19th century in the early 20th
century of the progressives was if we
use science the scientific method and we
establish knowledge about these social
problems in the form of the new
disciplines that are being established
in the social science you have sociology
that was established you have the social
science economics was a social science
anthropology history political science
those were all brand new attempts to
establish a theoretical or on let me put
it this way
they were meant to be the Applied
Sciences of the modern state the state
was the the mechanism and the the
vehicle for the administration of
progress but you needed
you needed a mechanism to produce the
knowledge and so the question you ask
which is I think becoming more difficult
to to suggest that the knowledge that is
established
theoretically about practical things in
my view is suspect now because I don't
know that it produces what is genuine
knowledge because in the older
traditions practical knowledge was never
understood theoretically it was through
theoretical or metaphysical reason was
always understood in terms of prudence
or practical reason because and that
meant that you dealt with these problems
that revealed themselves through the
ordinary senses that one has to to make
sense of the experience so
commonsensical knowledge was practical
knowledge and it did not have a
theoretical component but all the social
sciences established a theoretical lens
by which to understand practical
knowledge and the question then becomes
a question of whether or not the method
itself is reveals reality or distorts
reality and I've come to think that it's
more of a distortion of reality if it
cannot make sense if it does not make
sense of what the phenomenon actually is
in terms of whether it succeeds or not
there's a sense I get when I study this
that economics other social sciences
they have a sort of an Envy in a way of
the Natural Sciences though they want
that precision they want the prestige
they want to be able to say we've
conclusively demonstrated X or Y or Z
and it's we can do that now how much how
much of that certainly that's their
conceit I would say without question and
point two would be they didn't fulfil it
economics being the most successful but
still you know the dismal science and
all that it's done better than the
others but not great how much is that
though let's call it hubris is the
result of this
you know branch of philosophy thinking
that it has refuted the older
philosophic is the older philosophic
tradition at a kind of humility about it
so there are things that we can't know
there are things that are always going
to be maybe he's either ORS
you know 49 51 calls and things like
that so how much of it is hubris that
they can they can overcome it or how
much of it is just like we're just
blazing a new path because look where we
are after 2,000 years you know we
haven't solved these the problems no I I
think the first the first thing that
they take for granted which was the
Hegelian framework of the end of history
that history itself means that the
problems that the whole philosophic
tradition denied could ever result in
genuine knowledge about things
Hegel's analysis is philosophy is over
because we have it has revealed itself
it's completed itself and in the
completion of philosophy now you have
genuine wisdom or knowledge but that
knowledge is going to be scientific
knowledge right that's what I mean by
the hubris right well your prior thinker
would have said I can achieve all right
no I mean kind at all wisdom so we all
have to we all have to rein in our
expectations a bit and so I want to move
you know it sort of steer towards some
of the practical considerations of how
this comes about
I can rattle a few of them off one is
government and also the people
government serves they tend to come to
think well you know we can put a man on
you know the old saying you can put a
man on the moon why can't you do X or Y
or Z so they tend to have these
visionary expectations for what rational
politics can achieved because the whole
argument in the first place is on a
shaky foundation it's not achieved and
everybody we still spend a lot on it and
we don't get what we want everybody gets
more unhappy the other one that I really
want you to talk about because I think
it has a very direct bearing on 2016 is
government stops being political in the
sense that you may want a tariff I may
want free trade but I don't you know in
the older understanding I don't say I
have scientific proof that I'm right
neither do you we just go and argue it
out and somebody wins somebody loses or
we make a compromise instead it becomes
a matter of incorrect versus correct
and no matter what the people vote for
the administrative state has such a
weight and momentum it just keeps doing
what's always been done and you get this
massive frustration for people who want
to rule themselves politically but feel
like they can't and that's I think going
on here I think that's going on in
Europe and you know that that's I think
that's absolutely right but here's here
the the point in which that reveals
itself politically within the regime is
when Congress as a body as a legislative
representative body was meant to be a
deliberative body which means that it
publicly deliberated on the kinds of
issues that you're talking about which
meant then that the legislation or
lawmaking was the activity of
deliberation representation of interests
and the various ways in which Congress
as a public body came to some kind of
compromise about what it is that could
be established in law and so general law
is the product of deliberation or
rational deliberation is what how it is
that representative regimes establish
political rule when Congress gave up its
power to legislate and began to delegate
its authority to these agencies these
technical and and expert knowledge
agencies and mechanisms the whole
character of the regime changed and and
the legislative body became an oversight
body and it just paved the way really to
make it possible for the legislative
branch really to become much more adept
at representing organized interests
rather than pursuing a common good that
would result in the ability to establish
a consensus political consensus that you
people can live with by elections so
that brings me to two questions then the
first is you know yeah I just want to
ask why did Congress do that why would
you you know politicians supposedly want
power and if you haven't the power to
write laws or defeat laws you'd think
you'd rather have that then give up your
power and delegate it downward
now that the obvious the obvious answer
that most people give is well it's hard
to take controversial positions they can
be used against you and your reelection
campaign just much easier to defer all
that stuff not get pinned down in
anything and do constituent service and
is it that simple or they're bigger a
larger reason why they gave up their
power and the second question is you
know as you point out in the book and
I've heard you say many times Congress
moved from being a legislative body to
an oversight body but you point out
they're not even a very good oversight
body they don't use their their
remaining oversight powers nearly as
forcefully and strongly as they could
they hang back even with the one power
that they sort of ostensibly have left
why is that well I think what happened
in the mid sixties is that when the
whole of the 20th century in a certain
way and this is progressive intellectual
social science Authority that
established the way in which it was
thought that the powers of the executive
of the late of the American government
ought to be used and the executive
branch every almost all social science
put their hopes on the presidency to
establish a larger role in the economy
in society from the center the reason
why Congress was reluctant is it always
thought of its power in terms of its
state base and so Congress represented
constituencies and states and localities
and so you had an active political life
within the states Congress never was
tempted to think or never thought that
it could deliver better from the center
to the periphery in other words that
what did once I first once I realized it
that if if they brought great power and
and could compete with the executive
with the president that they too would
have a major role to play keep a like
Samuel Huntington in 1965 was writing if
Congress doesn't begin to participate in
national politics administrative policy
it's not going to have a role to play
all the power is going to go to the
executive branch
and he they were all calling for a
reform of the legislative branch but
what that would what that required of
course was that and the reason why you
didn't get the reason why Congress would
not do legislate and delegate its power
that it refrained from using power
making laws that would establish those
agencies once had decided that it would
create those agencies it really
understood by 1970 that they had to
change the way Congress understood its
role the legislative reorganization Act
of 1970 established large staffs it
basically adapted itself to the role of
oversight
now you're right oversight in the eight
70s and 80s certainly all the way into
the 90s when Congress was more
decentralized as a body and allowed
members to be subcommittee chairs
committee chairs that oversee that
oversaw the whole of the far flung
bureaucracy it broke it down and and
what that required though was that those
subcommittee chairs have great power and
can be able to monitor these things that
they were chair of over the course of a
fiscal year they can all then
participate in the markups and the
budgeting the budget making of those
agencies and when those subcommittee
chairs were on those committees long
enough they had as much knowledge about
what that agency was doing is through is
the experts once they gave that up once
they started centralizing power in the
leadership in Congress and and it
changed the character and it's much
harder now to for them to provide
oversight and it what it's done is it's
narrowing the number of people who
actually participate finally in what the
budgets are because really the budgets
are aren't made by and over and
coordinated by members of the
legislature they're made by the
bureaucracy
and when the bureaucracy use essentially
what its requests are then you've got
just a few leaders at the top that
determined what it is it's going to be
funded and what isn't the membership
either goes along or they have to shut
the government so it it's just the worst
way of doing almost anything I think the
way I put it in the reviews that
Congress sort of willingly accepted for
itself the status of junior partner to
the administrative state its handmaiden
and enabler but the next question I need
to change topics because to me the essay
that stuck out for me the most and I
think it's because I hadn't read it
before and I'd read a lot of the rest of
the book before was the essay on Nixon
and so I'll briefly summarize this I
think it was written first in 1982 so
eight years after Watergate if only
published about eight or ten years after
that yeah and it you know the first
glance you're getting a little kind of
Art Bell late-night radio feel here
spooky cue the spooky music is this man
crazy but when you think about it it
this case at least to me started to
appear convincing and it essentially
argues that the real deep undercurrent
of Watergate was the administrative
state figuring out that Nixon second
term was a real threat and we got to
find a way to get rid of this guy and
you start connecting all the dots of
what the administrative state did or its
various you know and we know the deep
throat for instance was the number two
man in the FBI that was disclosed to the
world in 2006 I think anyway
I came away from that feeling like I
really learned something new and had a
very fresh perspective and also talked
about relevance so I'd like to hear you
yeah what I what I thought it was really
hard to make sense of Watergate in
during the time it was going on partly
because there there it was shaped as a
legal problem and at the bottom of it of
course was a political problem that
revealed itself far before Watergate and
that was this the two branches and
particularly after Nixon won in 72 they
didn't have a common ground by which to
relate to each other the executive and
the legislative brain and and what I
mean what that means is
that but the problem with with the
administrative state is that it had
become impossible for both branches to
participate equally either as either if
it wanted to be a constitutional body
say the president wanted to act in a
constitutional way on the one hand and
the other part of it was Congress had
adapted itself to the administrative
state but nobody understood at that time
that in accepting the the legitimacy of
the administrative state you had
abandoned the way you had abandoned the
necessity of establishing separation of
powers as a viable way of working our
national government the national
government has two political branches
both have to protect their turf you know
the legislature protects the the
legislative branch and the executive the
executive both have to protect their
turf but both have to understand that
the defense of their institution is
first a defense of the institution but
secondly a participation in deciding
what the common good is so Congress has
a perspective on on lawmaking and what
the common good is from the
Legislature's point of view and the
executive from the executive but they
have to cooperate and once the
administrative state established itself
and its legitimacy and was constantly
trying to expand itself it became clear
that Nixon that you could not have an
administrative state and and consent of
the government at the same time he
thought political rule would not be
possible in the future if the
administrative state established itself
fully and established itself in a manner
in which the legislative branch was
really representative of interest rather
than the possibility of determining what
a common good is and so when I wrote
that thing it was it was entitled at the
time politics rhetoric and legitimacy
the role of bureaucracy in the Watergate
affair
because it seemed to me that that that
was the whoever controlled the
bureaucracy the fight was who's going to
control the bureaucracy and and Congress
had great mech and great tools to
control the bureaucracy they they and
when they came up against Nix who who
didn't abide by what they thought the
rules were then they there was some very
great changes that occurred in the in
the Nixon administration particularly in
the in the second administration they
passed the per congressional budget
impoundment Control Act because they did
they wanted their own organized
intelligence as to how to put the budget
together rather than depending on OMB
which was in these hands of the
executive they passed a campaign finance
reform War Powers Act all of these were
to me revelations that the two branches
were not on the same page I mean from
1921 when we you could say we created
the Bureau of the budget and all of
those administration's in between
Congress never wanted to participate in
control of the budget until night until
Nixon second term and they realized that
that that Nixon was going to use the
budget to undermine the connection
between Congress and the administrative
state so I thought it was you know it
was not first of all the Republicans in
Congress did not see this in a partisan
way they didn't see it even they
understood it in an institutional way
but not not a constitutional way really
what they understood was in an
institutional way was that they had made
their accommodations Republicans and
Democrats with the administrative state
with the interest and Nixon was a threat
to that and so it it wasn't partisan in
the sense that Nixon could count on a
party
in Congress to uphold his view what the
Constitution was and and so it was
really not easy to see what the role of
the administrative state was because it
was only starting to get rolling
but it could see it in hindsight thanks
to that piece and we certainly see it in
action now I mean if you think about
what the administrative state I mean
it's not honestly compared to what it's
doing to Trump it seems like they really
treated Nixon with kid gloves the amount
of oh yeah the amount of leaking on I
mean on to undermine the president I'll
be so bold as to say as far as I can
tell i knows what a special prosecutor
may or may not have but the whole
russian thing looks like a complete set
up designed to hamstring and undermine
the president you have whatever you
think of his policies no president has
ever faced this level of internal and
external but especially internal
opposition it's almost like the
administrative state is just on strike
waiting him out either doing what they
want to do without him or just not doing
the things they don't want to do I mean
to the point where and I realized that
this was apparently a political
appointee but it gets you to the spirit
of the thing you have an anonymous op-ed
writer in The New York Times saying I'm
in the administration and I'm doing
everything I can to stop it from doing
what it was elected to do so boy it
seems a lot more powerful now than it
did even then and if it brought down one
president yeah the prospects for this
one now but you know we didn't know at
the time yeah that that for one you
nobody suspected that the Justice
Department and and federal judges mm-hmm
you know Jeff Shepherd who was one of
Nixon's lawyers at the time now with the
benefit of freedom of information and
people dying and getting all the records
you read his book on what happened in
Watergate Nixon Nixon didn't know what
hit him in terms of the the the the
Justice Department would acted in a
completely unprofessional way the the
judge sharika was was it was having
private conferences with the prosecutors
all of the things that nobody would have
suspected at the time because we thought
that that the Justice Department
treated muscies it's it's this behavior
by by the rules of the rule of law what
we didn't realize them was what I think
we came to realize is those those
agencies and departments that were
constructed on technical expertise and
professionalism they viewed their
professional duty as paramount to even
the Constitution or the country and so
the Justice Department and and became I
I mean now it's clear it's pretty clear
that the Justice Department does have a
defense of itself the agencies have
defenses of themselves and and I think
when Comey says we've writing about a
higher loyalty he believes that
professionalism means that your loyalty
is to the knowledge you have and these
people that that are trying to undermine
you these ignorant people people that
still want politics new rule rather than
professionalism
it's hard to say then I mean which is
more dangerous and insidious that you
know the the anti-democratic Cabal
element or aspect of the administrative
state or the way in which the
administrative state saps the virtue
initiative whatever you want to call it
for self-government and Republican rule
by just sort of taking over little tasks
and life I mean Tocqueville certainly
talked about that yeah I'm just worried
about it you know you haven't said as
much about the latter but I think that
to me that you know that that's the vast
majority of what the federal behemoth
does is not try to kick out incumbent
presidents they would not have tried to
kick out President Clinton Hillary
Clinton that's for sure but no matter
who's the president that second aspect
of it just goes on and on and grows by
the day no and I think what when you
look at the presidents in the post you
know post administrative state because I
I date the the effects of the
administrative state as undermining the
Constitution as not through the not the
New Deal period I think it's between
1965 and 75 the
that it happens when Congress
reorganizes itself and establishes
itself as a different body and so there
were only in my views only two
presidents who understood that political
rule was incompatible with
administrative rule Nixon was at first
and and again it was there's not great
clarity in his mind about this I know
that but Reagan also understood it but
Reagan learned from from Nixon you you
couldn't make a direct you couldn't make
a a attack Congress directly in other
words Reagan's I think greatest success
was mobilizing public opinion about on
the on the question of whether or not
government's a solution of the problem
or is the problem and and that resonated
it resonated very effectively in the in
the electorate because when you look at
at the end of that by the end of the
1980s Reagan had in some ways D
legitimized what Roosevelt had FDR had
called liberalism which was a form of
progressivism and when they gave up when
when when the Democratic Party realizing
their they didn't want a that label of
liberalism when they turned to and went
back to the what they had at the
beginning of the century what Wilson and
all of them thought they were
progressives Hillary calls herself from
progressive in the 90s Obama calls
himself a progressive that was that was
that was Reagan's success but the but
every everything he did in in a kind of
indirect way to try to minimize or the
effects of using executive power to
minimize the power of the administrative
state which he did fairly effectively
through reconciliation the Ohio IRA
those those kinds of things were fairly
effective but by the 90s when Clinton
comes along he realizes you could use
those those those tools Reagan used to
to minimize the power of the
administrator
say and actually use executive power on
behalf of the administrative state and
as Congress legislated more legislates
more and more the power to the
administrative body it of necessity
gives greater power to the executive and
more discretionary power to the
executive because when when an activity
is not made by law but it's done by
administrative rulemaking then of course
Congress can't participate in the same
way as the executive branch can in
figuring out in discretionary matter on
in terms of discretion how they want to
how they want to administer those
particular things so there's no way out
of the administrative state in a certain
way of extending greater power to the
executive and greater discretion to the
executive so they all now use executive
authority rule you know many ways in
which you know the use of executive
orders or signing statements all of
those things are just ways in which con
presidents are trying to administer
these things these these policies that
are established but you're being
somewhat generous right when you say it
goes into the executive branch I mean it
doesn't it doesn't on the flowchart this
power goes into the executive branch
yeah but in reality if you define the
executive branch's the elected president
the the confirmed members of a you know
the Senate confirmed members
administration and in his his senior
staff at the White House they can't
really control the rulemaking bodies of
the brain I didn't be at a political a
PPA I meant the executive branch which
is part of the bureaucracy so yeah I
guess so yeah it's it's it's much harder
for the you know the political of Nixon
saw this to I mean he already saw that
when when he said you know I appoint
people to these offices that are
expected to take a presidential view and
what do they do they they go native and
they become part of that the bureaucracy
co-op's them because there's no
incentive for a political appointee to
go into
a big agency and be a threat to to the
people that have the institutional
knowledge in those agencies the only way
you succeed is to accommodate them and
Nixon was trying to say we want somebody
that can rule those but you can't do
it's not easily done what I'm saying is
political rule is not compatible with
administrative rule and political rule
is about law make an administrative rule
is about rule making and that means that
all of the participants participants who
are affected by rules have a greater
stake in Washington and want to
participate either to get advantage or
subsidies or relief of one kind or
another and so it's a good town for
organized injury it's a good town for
organized interest but it's not very
good for what one would call
establishing what the public good is
what's what's the common good that that
these institutions are created for in
the first place
I mean when you when you think about
these are offices that are created by
the Constitution on behalf of the people
if they don't do what they're supposed
to do like make laws and deliberate and
establish once they make a law that the
rule Falls equal to those laws fall
equally on everybody then if you start
establishing the rule of privilege you
start allowing privilege to dominate and
there's many many kinds of privilege
that are available in all of these areas
including of course the privilege that
comes out of the Justice Department
deciding who they will prosecute and who
they won't
that's not nobody could say that that
that is compatible with with rule of law
I said before the administrative stage I
think I use the word seems which is
preposterous of course it is far larger
than even it was when it became you know
Nixon put it in incites when Reagan was
worrying about it nothing seems to be
able to check its growth either as a
physical matter just in terms of the
number of people and the amount of money
it spends or in its reach so metropolis
in part he never used the phrase but
it was clear that on some and you were
the one who turned I say this in the
review you know you figured this out
before the rest of us and we're trying
to tell us in the very early stages of
the primary campaign on some intuitive
level he figured that out ran against it
I think he wants to stop it but is this
boulder just so heavy and the hill so
steep that nobody can stop it well I
don't know I I think the reason why I
had confidence and I don't say and Crump
the person I hadn't knew nothing about
from I just saw it
this guy is entering this race and his
perspective is not the perspective
either of an intellectual of social
scientists a Washington insider it's a
perspective of a citizen it was a
perspective of a common sensical view of
what politics should be and I don't I
mean the problem with the administrative
state is just think of all the organized
intelligence that's been produced in the
last 50 years a hundred years in the
American University where does it all go
it really comes to Washington right and
these people have an interest then in
utilizing that knowledge now I think the
real question here is the one you asked
before it's this real knowledge if it's
real knowledge things should have been
getting better all along but it's not so
clear that things have been getting
better and in the eyes of citizens you
just judge the regime on the basis of
the political character of it they think
is getting worse and so it's it's you
know this is going to be you have in a
way a kind of cast a cast that
establishes its authority in Washington
through the credentials that it has that
are established by these universities
that are supposedly establishing the
kind of knowledge about whether it's
foreign policy domestic policy economics
social problems all of these create a
huge a huge interest that is
hate they call it a and it's an interest
that is oblivious to the fact that it
also has its own self-interest at stake
in other words it thinks that it's doing
a good that can't be judged in turn in
political term it is I made that point
to the review that it's convinced you
bring this out it's convinced of its own
impartiality
it's very earnest in the way ya
understands itself so I've been in the
government a couple times and you will
always hear anytime the government or
some part of it does something I think
the words that I used were venal
partisan stupid or punitive you can
always count on permanent Washington to
rise and go on cable TV with one voice
and say hey these are just honest career
civil servants doing their jobs don't
criticize them and there I've met I
worked with so many these people and of
course that's true in almost every case
these are honest careers civil service
just doing their jobs the problem is
precisely that they're very very earnest
and they are most of them convinced that
they have their in maybe not possession
of wisdom but they know the truth of the
subject-matter they're there for yeah it
was a disdain of political disagreement
and a sense that my task is
implementation and not to be you know
bickering maybe back and forth between
these different views that's not
political rule in any sense really yeah
but also I think there's one other
element of the administrative state it
does have an intellectual and moral
defense of itself and the people who
were morally who it's safe believe that
organized intelligence is bringing us
into the future and the future is is
where we're striving to get there of the
opinion of course that the Constitution
and political rule is an obstacle to
that so it's a good for them I mean and
you can't discount the fact that many
people think that this is that the old
regime the the Constitution was immoral
unjust and and so the moral character of
post-modernism which establishes I think
kind of moral authority for the
administrative state as it now
understands it
you're at war really between an older
America and yeah and what was Erica can
become baked into the cake in a sense
from the beginning the initial very
earliest progressive although we get the
constitution is immoral later that that
emerges I think morons oh yeah mid 20th
century the initial argument is it's
just outmoded it's not for it society's
gotten too complex
we can't govern ourselves with these
powdered wigs anymore so we have to move
and the American people in their
foolishness or sentimentality are
attached to it so we're not gonna tell
them that were that we're going to we're
just going to maneuver around it under
in and over it and pretend like we
adhere to it alright so I think with
that we're going to take some of Otto's
questions I'm told that in the and I
hate to use the term Affordable Care Act
or Obamacare there were a hundred and
sixty thousand and 65 places where it
said the secretary shall yep talking
about delegation second part of that
would be are you familiar with the work
being done at the Scalia Law School of
George Mason who've been holding
conferences on just this subject oh yeah
delegation I'll say just very quickly on
the first point every law is like that
now no laws are laws laws are not laws
and there's still two thousand pages but
then the two thousand pages are just two
thousand pages of the Secretary shall
which really doesn't mean the secretary
it means the permanent bureaucracy
underneath the secretary and then they
write for a 2,000 page law they write
fifteen or thirty thousand pages worth
of rules that are the real laws well
Nancy Pelosi was right when she was
asked you know what's in the law and she
says I can't tell you that until after
it starts to get administered I mean
because it these are works in progress
but the the the the knowledge to to be
able to establish these rules are all
with with the experts and there was I
forget one of the senators saying
the time when they asked him if he had
read the law and he says I don't think
he want me to waste my time reading
these laws he says I have I have experts
to read this form and and so Congress is
you know well this is the way this is
the way these things are viewed and
they're also so long I don't know that
you know any yeah right we have you have
48 hours to comment on 2,000 pages and
it's just kind of okay so I think you
guys both talked about maybe the failure
of politics either in the since the
1960s
or perhaps even going back from that to
restrain the administrative state and
and to bring politics to restrain that
state and I think we see that for
example in Reagan being unable to
eliminate the Department of Education
even though it had only been around for
a year when he started trying what about
trying to bring politics to the
administrative state we've danced around
the distinction between career and
appointment is it time to make the case
the American people that we need to roll
back some of those career protections
those job protections and make them
directly accountable to elected
officials ie the president I'd certainly
be for that I mean keep in mind to just
very briefly John I know but our system
actually compared to a parliamentary
system typical in Europe has a far
deeper layers of political appointees so
the British look at the State Department
and they see wow your presidents gets to
appoint people all the way down to this
assistant and sometimes even the deputy
assistant level we have we have a
minister and two guys and that's it
amazing you must have much greater
control over your government than we
ever could you know maybe the joke is on
them in that sense I'd be all for it
with one caveat which is we have to get
every single one of those people
confirmed through the Senate they're
just going to be empty chairs and I'm
the impulsive Conservatives myself
included sometimes might be empty chairs
in the federal government
great what's the problem right feature
not bug
that you can't politically control as
this administration is finding to its
frustration in part because of so much
Senate obstructionism Democratic
obstructionism in particular you can't
really control these agencies without
your veneer of people whether that's the
top three layers or the top six layers
you've got to have people and if the
Senate has the power to hold them up
you're it's not gonna work I don't you
have any no III think we the the problem
with centralized administration is that
once it's centralized every interest and
almost once all the activity of human
life becomes political there is no
interest that doesn't organize and
mobilize itself around Washington it can
be social economic scientific religious
there's there's really no realm of human
activity that's immune to political
control in the modern administrative
state and so when you have that kind of
that the pervasive character of the
administrative state these interests
mobilized they they come to Washington
they have a presence in Washington to
try to to decrease the power and the
connections between those organized
interests and the bureaucracy and the
legislative branch is a great difficult
it's a very difficult task it's hard to
believe but you know in 1964 if you had
come to Washington you would have found
hardly any national economic social
interest that had a Washington office or
Washington lobbyists that meant that
still there was active political
economic and social life in states or
companies had to had to if they wanted
to lobby within the state they went to
Albany in New York or you know whatever
the stake have when you centralize
everything everybody wants to make one
decision right including the people if
we make it in Washington then how how
what did the states become they become
ciphers of the federal
government they are their role really is
to just administer what is done here
nobody who's ambitious who should be
perhaps in a state participating in
making local and political ruling states
better they they come here they use
their talent here we don't have a way of
having good political and social and
intellectual life outside of Washington
even they whatever it is in the in the
periphery like Hollywood or business in
New York it's all organized around
Washington so it's really hard to toe
fill was right don't decentralize if you
can help I mean we don't realize if you
can help it
yeah yes sir we we tend to know now
or suspect at least that incumbent
players in the private sector incumbent
industries or businesses in an industry
have an incentive to favor regulation
it keeps the the upstarts who don't
understand them out what are possible
countervailing incentives that Congress
can set up that would work against work
to corrode the power of the
administrative state well it's it's
difficult to say I mean once those once
the organized the big companies have
complied with the rigors of the
administrative state and those costs
then are factored in it's it's how do
you how do you any upstart company if
you'd have to deregulate in a way that
made the newer players not have to play
the game but nobody's gonna do that
Congress is not going to do that I don't
think I do you have a sense of what you
can do
no I you're right that Congress it's
still somewhat mystifying to me why I
mean
our system of government our
Constitution only works if you know
ambition counteracts ambition as Madison
put it and Congress doesn't seem to have
any ambition anymore right now nowhere
where did that go why did they seat it
why did it drain out of him because boy
the administrative states pretty
ambitious the other of the judiciary is
pretty ambitious but Congress seems to
just be perfectly happy with being I
mean they're irrelevant maybe oh we're
kind of a harsh word but not that
relevant and when it is relevant it
tends to just take its cues from the
executive like the president said well
I'm either party says I want this law
you get it you get me 51 votes and go
pass it they almost never take the
initiative to pass lit up almost if we
do they ever pass legislation buying
their own initiative anymore well you
have two things they have a great deal
of protection security they have a great
deal of power in terms of patronage to
all kinds of things and and they have
they have something that in politics is
could never be secure in political life
is precarious but administrative life is
safe in a way you can say they're just
like bureaucrats yeah when I did the
book called the Imperial Congress about
25 30 years ago what we showed was that
it was it was hard to defeat an
incumbent in Congress in the 1970s and
80s they had as much safety as the
Soviet Politburo people did so I mean
it's much harder now for the most part
right because of gerrymandering and
what's yeah science so-called the big
sort where blue districts just get blue
or red ones get red or so you have a
fewer competitive that must be part of
the explanation that you have fewer
competitive districts every every host
every cycle and the margin shrinks and
so if you're safe you're gonna play for
the long term and think about how you
can boost your fundraising and how you
can serve this constituents or this
interest group and so on and not think
about you know not not not think about
the common good or why you're really
there were you supposed to be there I
think one thing to the
made it harder in the 21st century and
really in the last decade of the 20th it
was the end of the Cold War because
there were the various constraints that
were imposed on the American political
order and the offices that were
established simply by the necessities of
the Cold War I mean there were rational
limits as to what American policymakers
could do the end of the Cold War and
this eforea about a world a global order
man in a certain way that they could
become global in their perspective about
how to think and and also how to these
administrative structures by the way
that are established are not just
demanding a nation they're there they're
there they're there put together by
professions by expertise the
non-governmental organizations economic
organizations economic large-scale
economic organizations are as
bureaucratic as government is in the
structures so that's a lot of temptation
you know you made a great point of the
book that since you brought up the end
of the Cold War that it really revealed
Congress's failure and almost impotence
that Cold War's over military's gonna
downsize we're gonna you know I'm from
California we had a lot of military
bases in California many many many of
them closed which contributed greatly to
the early 90s recession but Congress
couldn't find the will to deliberate
amongst itself to say what's the best
for the nation do we need this base do
we not need that base everybody just
wanted to protect the one in his
district no matter what and so they had
to it had to outsource it to the base
closing Commission yeah very process I
mean one here's a fundamental purpose
that they should have been able to do
that they're constitutionally elected to
do they couldn't do it so they outsource
it and that was you know in hindsight as
you point out that I mean you I'm sure
you understood it at the time I didn't
and hindsight reading about it in the
book wow that's a blinking red light
about Congress's failure isn't it yeah
it's it's
you know when you think about how much
Congress has delegated in ways that make
it easier for them to avoid political
problems that pose threats to
re-election you notice how how how apt
they are to when it's a controversial
issue they'll let the courts decide it
though there's always ways in which they
they they what they it's like when you
talk about ambition I've said for a long
time the American founders Hamilton
Madison which would say there's not
enough ambition to run this government
no political ambition real political
ambition with the view toward political
ambition means that you you desire
political greatness and that's just not
what what animates these people I mean
when it when I when a senator like my
senator from Nevada who was just as much
concerned with the sewer systems of
Nevada as he was with the big questions
it means that these are these these
people are they just want they they want
to manage affairs they want the control
rational rule is not political rule but
it does presuppose the necessity of
managing affair when you manage affairs
you manage affairs through every phase
there's there's no necessity to
determine whether something successful
or not it doesn't work you continue to
manage if it works and and you manage it
and and you know it won't work at a
certain point you still manage it that's
why when when McConnell said getting out
of Afghanistan is precipitous now what
he really meant was we've managed the
affairs there we've got a lot of
contractors and NGOs and people that
work there and have you know we've got a
presence there we need to keep that
managed yeah and a particularly passage
that stuck out for me I don't remember
it word for word but it's a paragraph
sort of late in the book you talk about
just a complete lack of accountability
for anything nope you know no failure is
ever acknowledged no mistake has ever
corrected no courses ever Jane
and nobody talks about and finally Trump
comes along and starts saying wow you
really failed you don't know what you're
doing that was a disaster people think
you're violating the rules of Washington
you're not supposed to call us failures
even though we manifestly are anyway we
have time for one more question
yes what's to prevent in the unlikely
scenario that Congress actually takes
back some of its power from the
administrative state what's to prevent
it from becoming or allowing its staff
to become just as powerful or numerous
as sort of what we see is the
administrative state so what's the
permit that sort of same bureaucracy
occurring within the legislative branch
rather than the executive well I think
that the first thing is if they do
things in the open then they're
vulnerable at the polls too so you know
the real good the real trick is is to be
able to win offices by not appearing to
be political in other words you simply
service needs you service constituencies
when you start getting political no
matter what the issue is you're you're
going to antagonize half the people that
don't agree that don't agree with the
position you take so the goal is is is
they have power in the staffs over the
areas in which they want to have power
but they don't want they don't want
transparency in the sense that a precent
etre is known for his political views
and because that makes you vulnerable
again and and so it's much harder now to
get them to act politically so to take
power back in a political way if they
and they wouldn't really want they they
have staffs their staffs really our
administrative staff their staffs are
well when you think about it
well when Roosevelt created the
executive office of the presidency in
1939 the the the Commission that did a
study of that said Roosevelt needs some
help and you know he he didn't have any
really personal any private staff that
was devoted to the particular areas of
expertise over which he could have some
advisors and when it when they said they
recommended that he have you know a half
a dozen Navy advisors that just worked
for him the president there we know that
there was no expert staff that was that
was given to the president in that until
1939 when I when when a senator Senate
Majority Leader like Harry Reid when he
was Majority Leader he probably had a
staff of a hundred and fifty that's not
a legislator that's an executive office
that's a small little office it's an
executive office and there's there's
there's there's hundreds of them in the
legislative in those arenas so the the
the staffs really are are necessary to
equip one branch to be able to
participate when it comes when it's
necessary to confront another branch
that's what was happening and even by
Nixon's time what you could see that
when Congress creates the bureaucracy to
mirror its committee structure and and
of course so it has great control over
the actual double bureaucracies of the
departments or at least it did in that
time so when Nixon just as an example
when Nixon decided that he was going to
do the opening to China the first thing
he did was refused to let secretary
State Rogers know that he was doing
anything everything that that Nixon did
with China was done through the National
Security Council in the executive branch
because he knew Nixon knew if they got
into State Department
workers would know right away when wood
would blow up the and by the way Nixon's
NSC Kissinger Tennessee was maybe forty
people sixty tops
it's got to be three hundred today so if
FDR was allowed 6 EO p staff in 1939 I
think the total AOP right now is about
3,600 Oh ya know it but when you see
that that means that the separation of
powers doesn't work the way it was
intended to Constitution because both
branches should be cooperating on behalf
of what is a national interests a public
good for the for the nation now yeah
they should defend their turf as a
legislature or the executive but that's
not what they're doing anymore now
they're there they're there trying to
determine how it is that you can control
where the real power of government is
which is in the administrative structure
I guess I would answer your question the
same way but more glibly which is even
if what you suggested we're come to pass
it'll be better than what we have now
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you John the book again
is unmasking the administrative state
he's gonna be signing copies and and the
reception to follow and I'd also like to
take a moment to recognize the finite
edge of this volume can misogi yeah
[Applause]
thanks
thanks to the Claremont Institute which
is the co-sponsor for our event this
evening I look forward to seeing you at
the next Hillsdale College event thank
you
[Applause]